okay this is gonna be different
should make sure it's working
I've never done like a full screen
stream like this I mean I open up
Photoshop make a new document
this is gonna be an emote stream so I'm
gonna go through some photos make some
emotes out of them I wanted to do I
wanted to make emotes uh earlier this
week but I just never got around to it
so now I'm holding myself accountable
let's make this what is the emote size
112 I think the one 1256 and then 28 so
that should be good
you
and
well I did last night was I went through
photos on my Flickr page of strong chess
players uh what album was good this
album was good so anyway I put together
a folder of pictures now I will have the
chat open I'm not sure if
we actually have the chat open on a
window here too
just so if I miss anything
[Music]
um I can't I won't have any excuses
there we go so I put together some
photos which
let's start turning into emotes I really
want to do the Sam Shanklin emotes
because he's probably the hottest player
on the planet right now and by hot I
mean uh like doing well at chess set had
a double meaning let's go
I just want to make sure my stream is
live
I'm info save
hey it is life
here Korean knife is here okay cool so
what I'm gonna do for anyone who doesn't
know the emote making process pretty
simple I'm gonna try and make at least
three in the next half hour
let's grab his face
not literally
coppy
pace
I convert this to a smart object this is
probably not the best way to make a NEMA
or the most professional but it's the
way I do it in a size ass down question
is how much of his hand I want in the
shot probably like this
maybe I could scale it up a bit more if
I do it diagonally
that weird
mmm
that's okay now I'm
that's a pretty simple process of just
brushing it out
and then once I got one done that I can
size it down for a couple more so and
now it's just a matter of painting
and do one outer layer
a hollow pass Pau 99 me has my phone on
my computer that way okay now I can see
everything and hello Chris HDTV thought
that was Jason Bennett no this is Sam
Jenkins Sam Shanklin is actually a great
player to photograph he's one of the
more emotional players
between him Kasparov and Landrum and
those are probably the top three to
photograph
zoom in here
want to be somewhat precise you turn the
hardness up
rid of that blue
you
yeah I might be over complicating the
process but
[Music]
you
I don't know it's gonna be simple once I
just get this done make an outline
around his head and now okay
now I can up the brush size
you
looks weird his hand is gonna not be
connected to anything that's okay
you
okay um starting to look decent
it's kind of a weird shape I'll scale
this up a little bit
you
try and frame it correctly - but one
thing when I do these I'm try and make
it like overly perfect
and somewhat of a perfectionist
but okay I guess it's a question do I
want to cut off his hand a bit towards
the end how this looks
that looks nice okay
rotate this a bit back let's go up
the same proportions
smooth this out
okay
that looks beautiful now the last step
oh hello to more people hello Ariel is
taken oh my gosh I just fall my dad
sorry about that that should be better
now
okay the last step is to sorry I'm
trying to like put my phone a place
where I can see it I need to access the
layers think I got everything there
let's invert this to black
okay I didn't get anything or everything
uh go back to masking
this is key it needs to look good on
light background and a dark background
of the size
very lightly get rid of some is some of
his hair
okay that should be good
so light and dark
and if i zoom out
hopefully people can tell that Sam
Shanklin his face is kind of covered
when balding confirms okay uh so let me
make this a PNG this should be the right
size yeah 112 so let's save this shank
112
PNG and unsaved
and then I'll just save two more image
size 56
when I ya which requires three different
sizes for emotes
112 pixels and then 56 and 28 so
slightly tedious now I think what I
wanted to that's saved right just huh
yeah that's saved okay what I want to do
is make or resize it back up and size it
back down it's not losing quality
okay that's really small
almost unrecognisable that whatever I
think usually when you're using twitch
on a computer it's like it's a 56 sighs
hopefully that should be okay I save as
ernõ PNG
and 28 wait today yeah I resized it okay
let's make sure okay so these are my
emotes
one down I'm only doing this for 25
minutes
25 more minutes I should say I am
hosting a tournament on me chess which
there is a chat which is here if people
want to join this tournaments I'll share
the link in the chat
how many emotes you have to do I'm going
to do as many as I can
but in 25 minutes I'll be starting a
tournament so let's go back uh and let's
pick another picture
they're in the downloads
yeah
[Music]
maybe I can do the Kasparov emotes
yeah let's do a conspiratii not this
great picture
make a new document save from last time
beautiful
we're going to bring this in
again it's a question how much of this
hands I want to include
the time limit for the tournament so the
time control is three minutes plus two
second increments will be a blitz events
uh it'll be seventy minutes long
um and it starts at noon it starts in 24
minutes
okay let's bring this in let's convert
to smart object
I'm not sure how much of his hands I
want to include
start like that
tilt it a little bit
he does look kind of tilted um a double
meaning
okay let's smash this
maybe I can try a different process I'll
use the quick select
few years ago I used Photoshop a lot
more why is it okay there we go
I used to be a lot quicker but anyway
yeah this looks nice
I was very nice look I wasn't much
easier Photoshop is great and then I'll
just fill it with with black go and then
I'll clean it up
you have to smooth parts of this out
let's turn down the hardness 50
that's - yes it's because it's so scaled
down I need hardness around like b5 or
something there we go
I just want to reduce harshness of edges
this is lighting massage here
you
go
you
bring back some of his face
you
some of his hair got destroyed
maybe it's okay yeah that looks fine if
people thought that Sam Shanklin is
balding this comes nowhere close
okay
is that good enough
that gonna be weird but the hands just
on the edge there I can scale it up a
little bit
a fun fact I actually I made a Kasparov
emote for what used to be crew 64 who is
now Gotham chess and I want I've kind of
regret making that but it was a good
emote like one of these other Apsara of
expressions
this'll be
okay this'll be mine
that looks nice
let's duplicate the background vert
clean this up a bit more
I need to
yeah let me
Edge's
you
for those of you who are used to
watching chess this is not the same uh
okay let me go in here like this awkward
hole between his fingers
okay we should be better
part of his finger there
okay
and then there's some whiteness around
the edges
okay that should be nice
you
you
oops
I'm just towards the edges it can be a
bit like fuzzy but
only you people can tell when it's
killed so far down
okay so we're gonna save this
this will be the first one Apsara 12
about six to seven minutes
um if there's a stone it's hard to look
at the chat and make emotes can someone
post can I post a picture of two apalla
yeah feel free to post a picture of
T'Pol of the only concern I have is a
copyright that if I use a picture that's
not mine then I would want permission so
all the pictures that I'm using I've
captured so they've have no concern
about copyright
but I'm sure okay I've I guess there's a
lot of people who just use random photos
for email it's and no one can tell
so PNG
Apsara 56
please Kaspari 56 his Twitter handle
it might be
wait I'm curious now Twitter
as far as oh it's because far of 63 okay
I was close
let's go back they've won more I have to
resize first
twenty-eight okay
gee okay Ariel is taken I'll trust that
that link is valid where's my chat
ah this picture that's the famous
picture that was I think that was that a
screen grab of the st. Louis chess club
broadcast I feel like that's already
been turned into an emote as well
that was a great picture though
[Music]
yeah I probably wouldn't use that though
for yeah for the reason that it's
probably already an email it's somewhere
and I don't own it but whoever has that
Emo's I'll have to subscribe to them
what wait did I save already forgetting
when I saved desktop wait I didn't save
it okay as far of eh PNG
okay two emotes down
decent
let's do another one
OOP where is my
where's my okay but some downloads there
we go I wanted to do a Carlson underman
would be cool doing NACA
this is a great expression
let's do this one it might be tricky
around the edges but let's try it
Hondo Ramirez reacting to his
his team losing okay
but okay Ramirez
so new file
wait a minute what just happen their
control new
changed 112 by 112 hello to more people
below Boca 25 thanks for the comments
hello a random chess guy lo Bruno rola
okay
this is an Apple Mac yeah I'm using a
Mac
I can't live with all my Mac
okay Alejandro wait what
okay copy this first
you
this might be the last one
or anyone who just joined I will be
doing a chest stream very shortly people
can join here there's only four people
wait no there's five people I can't
count so more people can join if you
want I'll be a blitz treatments
you
okay
the best
best way to ankle this probably
diagonally
again a bit tilted
his afro is so big I'd have to cut it
off just a little bit
okay
to convert to smart object
but should be okay wait what just
happened
okay convert to smart object mask
I'll try the quick select tool again
this is going to work as well now that
works terribly maybe just for this area
okay now it's brushing time hardness is
good bring back his hair
get rid of this
you
which I can use a quick select here to
you
you
it's a tedious process
why it was probably putting on putting
it off for so long but what to do
in one moment I'll look back at the chat
this is part of his path there just a
background and make his mouth like
bigger
okay sixty cents
you
there is gonna be tricky I don't know
what to leave and what to include maybe
I'll just like be creative and give him
some style
you
I'm going to cut this whole bottom part
off
or is that too much
no emotes allowed in the chat there
should be emotes allowed in the chat if
there's too much restriction then I'll
like to change the settings on my dot
I mean it's one of the points I'm doing
this is I want more emotes
okay um does that look that looks like a
weird shape scale that up a little bit
something's wrong with his nose
from a distance it looks off just move
this out
you
okay getting closer
you
come back here this edges fuzzy
and the hardness all the way up
you
okay looks decent
maybe this edge could be fixed
cool
that's gonna be hard to tell this is
Alejandro but hopefully the expressions
good enough
let's wait there's one more part just
this area I want to kill his face too
much there we go okay duplicate the
background that already looks decent
just as top part
you
hmm
you
not make an adjustment layer and just
brighten this a little bit
you
okay I like it
well the tournament starts in eight
minutes
there's eight people now nice
cool let's say this this will be the
last one Ramirez
PNG
looks at 112
you
you
you
all day 56
you
sighs of backup
okay then size it down again 28 cool
twenty-eight okay so I have my emotes
three more I know how many more I'm
allowed I think I have at least five
more I can submit someone's leaving
Ariel is taken is leaving I'll see you
later
Wan foof ji is here
now in the clips what's now in the clips
anyway
let's just see what I have
where they go
finder
so this is ally emotes I make this
bigger
as far as emotes and Shanklin emotes I
like it that was productive maybe I can
at least identify what picture to do
next
I have several more I'm another folder
here chest pics I'm just gonna put all
these other photos in the that same
folder
keep both keeper okay
so Carlson emotes it's a weird
expression but I'll drag listen for
later what else oh there's my my father
who adopted me do they make emotes out
of both of these okay
for later
I could make an Aussie emote but hold
off landrum an emote he has the best
expressions
of course a Carlson emotes
although I
he had the Carlson picture anything else
karma emotes oh one quick story about
this photo I was going to make this
photo emotes
yeah let's at least drop us in one quick
story and then we'll get to the
tournament if if you're not in the
tournament and you want to play me or
have a chance to play me or just play
people who are also wanting to play me
join this tournament it starts in about
three minutes one quick story about this
photo is that was it
about two weeks ago the covers of chess
life came out it's a chest Life magazine
and chest life kids and
this this image of Sam was on the cover
of Ches life kids except it wasn't the
photo that I took there's another
photographer we took a photo at like the
exact same time
and when I saw this image I thought it
was mine I got really excited and then I
compared the images and it's slightly
different and I it was someone else who
took that photo I'm sort of disappointed
about as I submitted all my photos to us
chess and they're so similar but they
didn't choose mine so anyway I'll have
photos appearing in chess life pretty
soon I think for next month something
with the protest League so there you
have it
I'm going to end the stream real quick
and then I'm going to change this the
title and then have a new stream so hope
you guys enjoy that that was new I've
been streamed using Photoshop ever uh
yeah let me end the stream and I'll be
back in two minutes for the tournament